dès 2011 l'établissement public
d'aménagement par saclay a mis en place
des inventaires faune flore les gammes
pour les habitats et les corridors
écologiques
donc les résultats de ces inventaires
font partie prenante du projet
d'aménagement du territoire et ils ont
également étaient à la base afin de
conforter ou restaurer les corridors
écologiques présents sur le territoire
donc les trames vertes et d'être en bleu
mais également pour créer restaurer des
milieux humides et terrestres en
complément de ceux présents
sur le territoire dès la phase de
chantier
le pea paris-saclay impose entreprises
des mesures à respecter en faveur de
l'environnement ça soit par exemple pour
les périodes de travaux donc ils doivent
éviter les périodes sensibles pour la
faune et la flore la reproduction pour
l'hibernation également la mise en place
de barrières pour empêcher l'accès aux
zones humides présent sur les emprises
de chantier
il y a également d'autres mesures comme
les chantiers donc à faibles nuisances
que donc faibles nuisances sonores et
faible exemple lumineuse la marque on
voit derrière nous et c'est une marque
qui a été réalisé en 2013 elle a été
réalisée en 2013 parce que on anticipe
le calendrier de réalisation des travaux
ou un habitat existant où on avait un
certain nombre d'espèces d'amphibiens
donc grenouilles tritons qui était
présent sur le rond-point de la vauvre
devaient être détruits par les par les
travaux puisque un réaménagement routier
étaient envisagées sur ce secteur dont
clamart a été réalisé en amont en 2013
pour pouvoir accueillir les populations
d'amphibiens qui ont été déplacées en
2014 de ce secteur qui n'était pas fait
rennes vers cette marque qui avait les
caractéristiques qui convenait pour les
accueillir
on est capable de savoir si les animaux
qu'on a déplacé se sont maintenus il se
trouve que c'est le cas puisqu'on a une
population de triton crêté et une
population assez intéressante
on a identifié chaque individu qu'on a
déplacé puisque sur la partie ventrale
ils ont des tâches qui sont
caractéristiques de chaque individu donc
on les a retrouvés donc on sait qu'ils
se sont maintenus et que ils ont grandi
suffisamment pour être à même de ceux de
se reproduire
on a des bons résultats on suit aussi la
bonne réalisation des travaux que l'on
propose